one of our comic-con sponsors pepsi has
a campaign about making all of your
summer moments of joy better with pepsi
now i thought that was perfect cuz i've
just noticed someone in our audience who
doesn't seem to be experiencing much joy
right now can we get a shot of that guy
right there yeah there he is
sir what's going on you seem very
unhappy
you know I've an idea let's get this guy
at Pepsi can you get him a Pepsi someone
get him a Pepsi there you go
all right yeah
cool so yeah you enjoying yourself now
sir yes definitely I was actually
enjoying myself the entire time but
early in the day I got some black-market
Botox from a street vendor so my face
was numb luckily it wore off around the
time you started talking to me okay now
wait a minute so it had nothing to do
with the Pepsi no that was a happy
coincidence let me reaffirm the Botox
wearing off is what allowed my face to
move and the Pepsi added to this summer
a moment of joy okay that's that's great
that's nice just to recap don't buy
street Botox and Pepsi brings joy okay
all right thank you yeah we got it yeah
I know thank you
you'll see everyone at Comic Con was
right back
you